[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
georges donc george est un petit garçon
qui a sept ans et il adore sa maman et
tous les soirs ils rentrent de l'école
avec elle en voiture et il passe par un
rond point sur lequel des magnifiques
fleurs plus belle que ça en réalité et
un soir le petit georges à la
merveilleuse idée de sortir de la maison
d'aller arracher les fleurs et d'aller
les offrir à sa maman alors ici le
comportement de george hill est négatif
il est sorti de la maison il n'a pas
demandé la permission et c'est peut-être
mis en danger mais l'intention derrière
son comportement elle elle est positive
il voulait faire plaisir à sa maman
derrière tout comportement humain et une
intention positive alors j'aurai
grandement besoin de savoir ça quand
j'étais plus jeune
en fait j'ai souvent pensé que si
j'avais pas eu la famille aussi génial
que celle que j'ai eues j'aurais
peut-être développer une forme de
schizophrénie ou de bipolarité
en fait quand j'étais tout petit
un petit rien me faisais avoir des
réactions complètement disproportionnée
mon frère a récemment retrouvé cette
photo qui démontre bien l'intensité des
émotions je pouvais ressentir alors à
l'époque une petite injustice pouvait
mettre dans une colère est immense
une petite remarque dans une grande
tristesse je comprenais pas ce qui
m'arrivait je me sentais différente
j'étais souvent en fait perçu comme
celle qui dérangeait et c'est avec un
besoin viscéral de comprendre ce qui
m'arrivait que je me suis passionné pour
les gens différents
pour ceux qui réagissent trop et ceux
qui réagissent pas assez aussi donc je
suis devenu psychologue et c'est en les
étudiant que je me suis comprise et en
découvrant leur hypersensibilité que
j'ai compris la mienne alors la
sensibilité qu'est ce que c'est eh bien
c'est la capacité
et à discriminer une personne normale va
percevoir par exemple les grands
mouvements émotionnel chez l'autre la
joie la peur la honte la surprise une
personne qui est hautement sensible va
percevoir des micros changements dans
son environnement
ça peut être un petit mouvement deuil
une légère augmentation du rythme
cardiaque ou un changement dans la
couleur de la peau de la personne ce qui
se passe c'est que même si la personne
va capter et ressentir ce changement
fortement elle n'est pas forcément
capable d'expliquer d'où ça vient
elle va avoir un genre de sentiment que
quelque chose de différent ou que
quelque chose ne va pas en fait ce que
la recherche nous démontre c'est que le
dénominateur commun entre le génie et la
folie c'est cette hypersensibilité ce
qui déconnecte sont en fait ceux qui
connecte trop alors quand on touche
quand on ouvre le larousse le
dictionnaire pour y trouver une
définition de la folie on trouve
plusieurs choses gentilles très que deux
la première c'est la définition d'un
trouble mental et la deuxième qui me
semble absolument indissociable de la
première c'est celle de la passion dire
je suis fou de quelqu'un ou foot quelque
chose c'est en être complètement
passionné des quelque chose dans la
folie en fait qui est relié à
l'intensité du ressenti et c'est le
point commun avec le génie le génie on
parle aussi de douance intellectuel de
haut potentiel intellectuel du fait
d'être surdoué tout ça c'est la même
chose c'est avoir un excellent
fonctionnement cognitif mais également
et je dirais avant tout une grande
sensibilité une hyper réactivité à
l'autre et à l'environnement
les personnes surdoué et j'en ai tous
les jours à la clinique dont avoir des
réactions et des émotions intenses parce
que justement elles perçoivent davantage
de choses dans leur environnement
alors je suis pas en train de dire que
toutes les personnes hypersensibles son
surdoué puisqu'en fait
l'hypersensibilité représente 15% de la
population tandis que la devance ses 3 %
en revanche tous les surdoué sont des
hypersensibles quand on porte ce génie
on imagine souvent une personne pour
laquelle tout est facile et qui réussit
dans tous les domaines et ça peut être
le cas de certains d'entre eux il y en a
aussi beaucoup qui développe des
addictions des phobies scolaires ou même
qui peuvent se retrouver dans la rue
pourquoi parce que leur hypersensibilité
leur hyper réactivité à l'autre et à
l'environnement peut les rendre très
vulnérable alors malheureusement en tant
que société qu'est ce qu'on a tendance à
faire non magnétique est et on se
distancie de la personne c'est facile ça
nous permet de nous poser de questions
puis de dire je suis pas comme lui
pourtant cette fragilité cette
sensibilité là on pourrait s'en servir
comme une ressource incroyable le
chercheur kelly wilson explique que
quand on a des difficultés c'est un
petit peu comme si on marche avec des
cailloux dans nos chaussures et les
cailloux fonds man
nous devons prendre des antidouleurs au
pouvoir continuer à marcher
est ce que ce serait pas plus
intelligente s'arrêter de marcher de
regarder ces petits cailloux de plus
près pour comprendre ce qui les a amenés
là les personnes qui sont hautement
sensibles vont détecter et ressentir les
tout petits cailloux dans leurs
chaussures et pour cette raison là vont
se mettre à crier beaucoup plus fort et
beaucoup plus vite que les autres
alors le fait de crier le comportement
il peut être négatif
mais l'intention derrière elle elle est
positive c'est celle de détecter ces
petits cailloux et de les enlever alors
pour ma part j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
j'ai une maman qui m'a très bien aidé à
identifier les petits cailloux dans mes
chaussures et kim a rapidement appris à
les enlever
mais malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
de tout le monde
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais je
crois pas qu'ils aient solution miracle
je crois qu'il ya 7.5 milliards de
petites solutions et c'est chacun
d'entre nous car aider autrui passe
d'abord et avant tout par céder soi même
on a besoin d'aller soit même bien
d'avoir de la ressource pour pouvoir
aider l'autre ensuite elle rien un outil
qu'est merveilleux pour ça qu'ils disent
depuis 1998 et qui permet d'étudier
l'être humain en y portant un regard
positif
ça s'appelle la psychologie positive et
ça pour des finitions la science du
fonctionnement optimal de l'être humain
autrement dit comment est ce que l'être
humain fait quand il fonctionne bien
de quoi est ce qu il a besoin pour bien
fonctionner la psychologie positive
s'est imaginé que la vie c'est comme
être sur un bateau est au fond de la mer
il ya les roches qui sont les
difficultés les problèmes qu'on peut
rencontrer et le niveau d'eau c'est
notre niveau de ressources
psychologiques notre niveau d'énergie
quand on rencontre des difficultés
on va puiser dans notre niveau d'eau
pour les gérer je prends un peu d'eau
pour les difficultés professionnelles un
peu d'eau pour les difficultés
relationnelles un petit peu d'eau pour
les imprévus
le problème c'est que si je ne sais pas
comment rajouter de l'eau sous mon
bateau à un moment donné je me retrouve
sur les roches et c'est d'ailleurs
souvent à ce moment là qu'on va
consulter un psychologue qui va nous
aider à identifier les raches peut-être
à réparer notre bateau et à anticiper
les roches à venir et c'est absolument
essentiel mais il est tout aussi
important de comprendre comment est ce
que je peux faire pour ajouter de l'eau
son bateau alors une des choses qui peut
nous aider tous à rajouter de l'eau sous
nos bateaux et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
ce sont les émotions positives
20 la joie la gratitude la sérénité les
émotions positives en fait on a souvent
pensé qu'elle servait à rien on se
trompait les recherches de barbara
fredrik von démontrent qu'elles ont deux
fonctions principales
la première est qu'elle rajoute de l'eau
sont nos bateaux et la deuxième c'est
qu'elle élargisse notre champ de vision
en fait quand ça va pas on a tendance à
se focaliser sur le détail tandis que
quand on ressent des émotions agréable
quand ça va bien on est davantage centré
sur la globalité on des zooms les
émotions positives ont ce potentiel à
créer de l'ouverture à l'autre à la
différence et à ce qu'on voit davantage
ce qui nous rapproche d'autrui la
globalité plus tôt puisqu'ils nous en
différencie le détail je crois que passé
de la folie au génie en tant que
personne mais également en tant que
société c'est commencer par se changer
soi c'est arrêter de regarder ce qui va
pas chez l'autre et commencer par se
demander qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi
pour changer et impacter la situation
différemment car ce regard que l'on
porte sur l'autre a le pouvoir de le
rendre malade ou sans ce regard que l'on
porte sur la différence sur la
pathologie peut enfoncer ou élevé ça
dépend de nous tous et on a tous en nous
une certaine sensibilité dont on peut
chercher à s'éloigner ou à se rapprocher
je crois que la folie en tant que
société s'est cherché à mettre à
distance notre propre sensibilité
comme le dit si bien monsieur poser di
borgo le fameux monsieur tétraplégique
du film intouchables
et si la fragilité n'était plus
synonymes
de mise au ban de la société elle
pourrait alors être source de cohésion
d'un mieux-être ensemble de forces au
centre d'un projet de société
je rêve d'un monde où la loi du plus
fort serait transcender je rêve d'un
monde où les personnes hautement
sensible et notamment celle qui
dysfonctionnent serait davantage écoutés
comme étant des détecteurs affinée des
petits cailloux dans la chaussure dans
nos familles dans nos entreprises et
dans nos sociétés je rêve d'un monde où
chacun d'entre nous travaillent à
développer son niveau de ressources pour
pouvoir davantage s'intéresser à l'autre
dans toute la beauté de sa différence
je rêve d'un monde où on s'intéresserait
mois au détail il est différent mais on
regarderait davantage la globalité
il est humain et donc comme moi il est
vulnérable
pour moi ce serait salle jenny sur un
plan sociétal
alors je terminerai par cette anecdote
d'une personne qui a demandé un jour un
martin luther king est ce que tu crois
que ce sera toujours comme ça le monde
un lieu où le fort domine et méprisent
le faible et il lui avait répondu oui ce
sera toujours comme ça à moins que
chacun d'entre nous accueillent ce qui
est faible et brisé à l'intérieur de soi
merci marine d'aiguilhe amicaux
[Applaudissements]